this episode of legal eagle was made
possible by skillshare learn to think
like a lawyer for free for two months by
clicking on the link in the description
[Music]
yeah that is manslaughter bordering on
negligent homicide a jury would convict
willy wonka like that
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer
today i am very excited to start a brand
new series on this channel where i
examine your favorite fictional works
to tell you all the laws that have been
broken during the course of that movie
or tv show
today we're going to start things off by
examining one of my favorite childhood
movies willy wonka and the chocolate
factory
let's see if i can ruin your childhood
as much as law school ruined mine
be sure to stick around until the end
where i give you my verdict as to how
much money willy wonka owes
and how long he's going to jail
a little background about myself i have
been a practicing lawyer for over
10 years i am admitted to the bar in
five states including the district of
columbia
i have handled hundreds of millions of
dollars worth of cases both on the
plaintiff
and the defense side and in my spare
time when i have any
i teach law students how to kick ass in
law school
i serve all his tv dinners right here
he's never even been to the table
so i am eminently qualified to examine a
work of fiction to tell you all of the
laws that it has broken
so without further ado let's dig in to
willy wonka and the chocolate factory
hi mr jopek ah come along charlie you're
late
it's petty mr joe peck you're right
there you are thanks
say hello to your grandpa joe okay okay
big problem right off the bat charlie is
way too young to have a paper route i
think this is a
child labor violation here this is
governed by the federal labor standards
act or flsa
which states that no one under the age
of 14 can hold a job in the united
states
so later on in this movie mike tv
actually mentions that he's 12 years old
and because i think all the children are
supposed to be exactly the same age i
think charlie is
clearly under the age of 14. therefore
while mr jopek here may be thinking he
is doing a good thing he is actually
committing
a child labor violation
[Music]
what's happening willy wonka's opening
this factory's gonna let people in
you sure it's on the radio and he's
giving truckloads of chocolate away
class dismissed no no it's only for five
people
class undismissed he sent him five
golden tickets and the people who find
him will win the big prize where is he
hitting the tickets
inside five local bars you gotta buy
wonka bars to find them
okay big problem here this is a clear
violation of sweepstakes law that exists
in most states
you might notice that whenever you see a
giveaway on tv
there's always some fine print that says
no purchase necessary
there is a very very good reason for
that the reason is if you require
purchase you're no longer a free
giveaway and a sweepstakes
you are in a legal lottery that's the
difference between gambling in a lottery
and a sweepstakes which is just a
giveaway that's why you always hear that
no purchase is necessary and you can
participate
in the giveaway without actually making
a purchase
willy wonka has not added that language
and he explicitly requires you to buy
his chocolate bars in order to
participate in the golden ticket hunt
that is a clear violation of sweepstakes
law and my guess is that he would be
on the hook for the millions of dollars
that people have spent buying wonka bars
in order to participate
in this particular sweepstakes if you're
not 3d
you will go far i want it now what's the
matter with those two
for five days now the entire flipping
factory's been on the job
they haven't shelled a peanut in there
since monday they've been shelling
flaming chocolate bars from
dawn to dusk make em work nights
come on come along you girls put a jerk
in it or you'll be on your ears every
one of you
and listen to this the first girl that
finds a golden ticket
gets a one-pound bonus in your pay packy
what do you think of that
[Applause]
all right that is another flsa violation
he is clearly pushing his staff
far far too hard they're working for
five days straight from dawn until dusk
he's making them work overtime without
paying them anything extra
that is a clear violation that's called
a wage and hour violation i have friends
who
specialize in these kind of wage and
hour violations under the flsa
and they will tell you that the damages
and this kind of case really really
start to add up
because not only do you have to pay them
back pay for all the extra work that
they have done but you're probably gonna
have to pay them overtime and
on top of it you're gonna pay statutory
damages so for the thousands of workers
that this man has
in his factory he's gonna be on the hook
for hundreds of thousands if not
millions of dollars in wage and hour
violations
not good
[Music]
chocolates incorporated now listen
carefully because i'm going to make you
very rich indeed
mr wonka is at this moment working on a
fantastic invention
the everlasting gobstopper if he
succeeds he'll ruin me
so all i want you to do is to get hold
of just one everlasting gobstopper and
bring it to me
so that i can find the secret formula
your reward will be
10 000 of these all right so what
slugworth is trying to do here is engage
in corporate espionage basically trying
to steal a trade secret
if the gobstopper had been publicly
released then there would be nothing
that could stop
slugworth from just simply buying one
and trying to reverse engineer the
everlasting gobstopper
however since the everlasting gobstopper
has not been publicly released it still
probably qualifies as a trade secret
under willy wonka so by asking charlie
to find an everlasting gobstopper and
bring it back to slugworth
he's essentially asking charlie to
engage in a conspiracy to commit
a trade secrets violation now i know
everyone's going to say but slugworth
actually works for willy wonka
but here's the thing a conspiracy can
have different men's rheya for different
members of the conspiracy that's how
you have a police officer who engages in
a conspiracy who's not guilty of the
conspiracies
all the other co-conspirators so you
might get a weird situation where
charlie has violated the trade secrets
act by engaging in this conspiracy while
slugworth
has not
now will the children kind of step out
here
floods far frost of flippery accidents
what kind
of ass i didn't know we had to sign
anything for this tour
i can't see what it says in the bottom
violet
you first sign here hold
it let me through here you kids violent
baby don't you sign anything there
what's this all about
standard form of contract don't talk to
me about contracts wonka i use them
myself they're strictly for suckers
yes but you wouldn't begrudge me a
little protection a drop
i don't sign anything without my lawyer
my broker don't find anything either
then she don't go in
i'm sorry rules of the house okay so
willy wonka is trying to get the
children to sign a liability waiver to
limit how much exposure he has when
things go terribly terribly wrong
now i probably don't need to tell you
that if you can't physically read the
contract
that's going to be problematic for the
person that's trying to disclaim the
liability
that's called an unconscionable contract
there is some procedural or structural
problem with the contract itself
that makes it unconscionable for the
courts to enforce
and if you can't physically see the tiny
print at the bottom of this contract
that is a textbook unconscionable
contract but on top of that willy wonka
is going to have some problems with
signing a contract with
these children only the children here
have signed them they are minors
the parents while they are present are
not the ones signing this contract
when a child signs a contract generally
speaking that contract is voidable
at the option of the minor on top of
that this contract seems to be complete
gibberish generally speaking with a
limitation on liability you can disclaim
things like negligence but you can
almost never disclaim recklessness
this contract doesn't appear to do any
of that maybe that's in the fine print
that no one can see
but it appears to be just a string of
legal sounding words that don't actually
have any real meaning
so i'm gonna go out on a limb and say
that willy wonka has not disclaimed any
of his liability and he is going to have
problems with civil suits later on down
the line for his negligence and
recklessness
what do you think will come above
that what are they doing there it must
be creaming and sugaring time
well they can't be real people well of
course they're real people
stuff and nonsense no oompa loompas oh
lupa land there's no such place excuse
me
i am a teacher of geography oh well then
you know all about it
and what a terrible country it is
nothing but desolate wastes and fierce
beasts
and the poor little oompa loompas were
so small and helpless they would get
gobbled up right and left
a wang doodle would eat 10 of them for
breakfast and think nothing of it
so i said come and live with me in peace
and safety
away from all the wang doodles and horn
swagglers and snazz wangers and
rotten vermicious knids snozzwankers
vermicious knits what kind of rubbish is
that i'm sorry but all questions must be
submitted in writing
and so in the greatest of secrecy i
transported the entire population of
oompa-loompas to my factory here
okay so what willy wonka has admitted
here is a
huge immigration violation he says that
he secretly transported the entire
population
of a separate country of lupulan
to his factory a lot of problems here
number one i don't see
any reasonable way he could have
transported an entire country
legally through immigration channels on
the other hand it sounds like the oompa
loompas were
really facing quite a hardship in their
native country so conceivably they could
have been
refugees seeking asylum in the united
states or the uk
which actually might have allowed it to
go through but i don't get the sense
from willy wonka that he went through
the proper channels
for an asylum claim either additionally
it sounds like he made a quid pro quo
deal with the oompa loompas that he
would transport them
from lumpaland which is ridiculous
sentence to say
to his factory where they would live and
work and it doesn't seem like he's
paying them
anything that seems like a clear
violation of the 13th amendment's
prohibition against slavery and
indentured
servitude it really does sound like he
has transported these oompa loompas away
from a place where they were in fear of
being eaten alive
every day so that they could become
indentured slaves to his factory
i don't like the look of it this is a
kids movie right
augusto sweetheart save some room for
later
oh uh agustus please don't do that my
chocolate must never be touched by human
hands
please don't do that don't do that
you're contaminating my entire river
please i beg you augustine
my chocolate oh my beautiful chocolate
don't just stand there do something help
okay so augustus fell into the chocolate
river because there was clearly no
handrail protecting people from falling
in osha or the occupational safety
and health administration requires that
there be a handrail built to certain
specifications to protect
people like augustus from falling in on
top of that augustus was
touching a food product with his bare
dirty hands which hadn't even been
washed
and clearly contaminating this entire
chocolate river don't worry he can't
drink it all
in fact if we rewind the clip to see the
entire chocolate river we can see a
number of health and safety violations
so if we take a look at this scene we
can see numerous health and safety
violations that would shut this factory
down immediately
number one we can see the osha violation
that there's no guard rail protecting
the oompa loompas from falling inside
we can also see that none of the oompa
loompas are wearing hair nets
so all of that green hair is going to
contaminate not just the river but all
the other food products as well
at least the oompa loompas are wearing
gloves so they've got that going for
them
on the other hand augustus gloop was
touching the chocolate river with his
bare hands and has contaminated
everything
augusto sweetheart save some room for
later
on top of that there is no segregation
between the candies that contain
nuts and the candies that don't contain
nuts which means that
anyone could have an allergic reaction
because of cross-contamination
on top of that there appear to be plants
and trees growing on the factory floor
itself in addition to probably
mold and other fungus so there's no way
that this factory could possibly be
sterile enough
to produce a food safe product so all of
these violations in and of themselves
would require the factory to shut down
immediately because of violations of the
fda and other health and safety statutes
they're not making any chocolate anytime
soon why don't you try simply reading a
book
don't touch a thing
and in addition to the prior health and
safety violations we just talked about
this room appears to have literal
garbage strewn about the entire factory
floor
what's so bad about it this little piece
of gum is a three-course dinner
bowl no roast beef but i haven't got it
quite right yet i don't care oh
i wouldn't do that i really wouldn't so
long as it's gone then that's for me
violet now don't you do anything stupid
what's it taste like
fabulous it's tomato soup
it's hot and creamy i can actually feel
it running down my throat
stop don't why doesn't she listen to mr
wonka
because charlie she's a nitwit it sure
is great soup
hey the second course is coming up roast
beef and a baked potato
mmm with sour cream
what's for dessert baby dessert here
comes
blueberry pie and cream it's the most
marvelous blueberry pie that i've ever
tasted
holy toledo what's happening to your
face cool it dad let me finish
yeah but your face is turning blue
violet you're turning violet violet what
are you talking about
i told you i hadn't got it quite right
yet you can say that again
look what it's under my kid it always
goes wrong when we come to the dessert
always violet what are you doing now
you're blowing up i feel funny
so here violet beauregard has been
permanently disfigured by being
basically turned
into a blueberry i got a blueberry for a
daughter
potentially under a negligence or
recklessness theory willy wonka is on
the hook
for whatever monetary damages are
attributed to being permanently
disfigured in that way
it might sound crazy but there's
actually a very famous law school case
called the hairy hand case
where a doctor promised a normal hand
but delivered a hairy hand and the court
had to determine the difference in value
between a normal hand versus an
unseemingly hairy hand so the courts are
in a position to determine
what the damages are associated with
being turned into a blueberry
on the other hand willy wonka might
argue that violet disregarded his
warnings and literally plucked the piece
of gum out of his hand
against his warnings not to eat it and
that
might potentially work but the thing
about product's liability is it's often
strict
liability which means the courts don't
actually look at fault per se
they just look to causation did a given
product cause the harm
associated with someone's damages so
it's possible that comparative fault
won't be an issue and willy wonka will
be on the hook
all right so it looks like the wonka
factory is evacuating the air directly
out into the outside environment and the
same with the chocolate river which
looks like it was flowing
just right out into the environment into
waterways then polluting into rivers and
streams
i probably don't need to tell you that
this is an environmental protection
agency
nightmare who knows what's happening to
the environment because
of the pollution that this factory is
producing he's likely to be fined
severely for this kind of environmental
pollution
i want the works i want the whole works
presents and prizes and sweets
[Music]
yeah that is manslaughter bordering on
negligent homicide a jury would convict
willy wonka like that
here once again willy wonka has taken no
precautions whatsoever to protect people
from
falling to their deaths as a result of
falling into this equipment there are no
guard rails there are no warnings
whatsoever i don't think it would be
very difficult for a jury at all
to pin the blame on willy wonka and to
find that he's responsible not just for
the civil violation
of wrongful death but also the criminal
violations of negligent homicide or
manslaughter because of his reckless
conduct
and the fact that he is knowingly
putting these people in this situation
where they can easily die if you are
wise to
listen to me so the factory's yours
charlie you can move in immediately
and me absolutely what happens to the
whole family i want you to bring them
all
but charlie don't forget what happened
to the man who suddenly got everything
he always wanted
what happened he lived happily ever
after
yeah such a heartwarming ending the only
problem is that because
charlie has won this as a result of the
contest
he's got to pay taxes on his winnings so
while charlie may be very happy in the
moment
he doesn't realize that he's going to be
saddled with a tax bill in the tens if
not hundreds of millions of dollars
so unfortunately he's probably gonna
have to liquidate a large portion
of the wonka factory in order to settle
up with the irs
the truth is when you get everything you
want you don't really live
happily ever after sorry
[Music]
so let's tally up willy wonka's civil
and criminal liability here
first willy wonka engaged in numerous
osha violations which resulted in
serious foreseeable injury the workplace
hazards alone resulted in the deaths of
apparently four children so let's assume
about 20 million dollars
per injured child that comes to 80
million dollars on top of that willy
wonka engaged in the illegal practice of
indentured servitude
i'd peg those civil violations somewhere
around five million dollars for the
oompa loompas and additionally
willy wonka engaged in an illegal
sweepstakes lottery
that probably cost consumers somewhere
between 100 and 200 million dollars
in purchased chocolate which you will
have to discourage which puts willy
wonka's civil liability somewhere in the
neighborhood of 235
million dollars so you get nothing
you lose on the criminal side it seems
like willy wonka is guilty of
numerous crimes against children
including multiple counts of reckless
endangerment
i feel funny numerous counts of
manslaughter and potentially negligent
homicide
he's blocking all the chocolates
i think conservatively each of those
violations could bring with it
a jail time of 20 to 30 years so
multiplying that by the four children
that are permanently disfigured or dead
as a result of willy wonka's actions
i would say conservatively willy wonka
is going to jail for between
80 and 120 years good day sir
i said good day
[Music]
with sweatshop owner and murderer w
wonka in prison
charlie's gonna have to ramp up his
skill set pretty quickly otherwise he'll
have to lay off all the oompa loompas to
pay off his tax bill if charlie wants to
make candy as great as wonkas he should
probably check out skillshare's culinary
courses
like lisa long's class on making english
toffee
and since charlie is only 12 years old
he's going to have to learn how to run
a business on his own he should check
out jay hutch's class on
starting an online business from scratch
skillshare is an online learning
community that has over 20
000 classes on everything like lifestyle
design and technology
the first 500 legal eagles will get two
free months of skillshare when you click
on the link below
the free premium membership gives you
unlimited access to must-know topics so
you can improve your skills and learn
new things
it's like getting a golden ticket to
success without all the child murder and
tax evasion
so click on the link get two free months
of skillshare and start learning today
and until next time i'll see you in
court